Miranda is just an incredible
cheerleader of music that she believes
in and it's hard to put into words how
much it means to really have her belief
in word for it you know it's one thing
to really look up to somebody and
consider them a hero in your eyes and I
think it's another thing to meet them
and realize that they're even more than
you would imagined they could be and to
hear from her in times of like
celebration and also in hard moments to
be able to reach out and be like oh my
gosh you know this is how I'm feeling
about this and and her responses are
always just incredible having her there
to reach out to is a dream
[Music]
Claire
but give me I'm just a skin for people
that don't know any music effing we're
gonna hear this album what do you want
people to hear about - Neil talents
I want this record to be a metaphor for
a place where people can really come
together and be reminded of who they are
and reminded that they're not alone in
their story and reminded of their dreams
four times you see a winner sounds where
are those trophies already keep them I
have them still I'm like in the middle
of a flood renovation right now so they
are safe in their boxes waiting for a
safe place to go